cuáles son las causas para que en medio
del panorama global haya buenas
perspectivas para esta región
bueno valentina muchas gracias por tener
en el programa a ver yo creo que el
fondo monetario encontró dos cosas que
hemos encontrado los analistas también
nosotros los analistas del mercado pues
es que en latinoamérica en gran parte es
una región que funciona como despensa
para el mundo o sea latinoamérica por
ejemplo brasil argentina exportará una
cantidad de granos al mundo es muy
importante colombia exporta una cantidad
de ganado digamos si el precio de la
carne se ha incrementado a una forma muy
fuerte muchos alimentos los precios de
los alimentos están más altos y además
los precios de los minerales también
están mucho más altos pues en gran parte
por una demanda muy fuerte por el
digamos el cambio en la matriz
energética del mundo por el cambio
climático se le ayuda mucho a perú le
ayuda a chile' etcétera y por último en
los precios del petróleo mucho más altos
que le ayudan a países como colombia
en ese sentido entonces a pesar de la
pésima noticia digamos de mayor
inflación y esa crisis tan horrible que
estamos viviendo en ucrania a pesar de
eso que implica una disminución del
crecimiento global pues hay una parte
relativamente positiva para
latinoamérica porque es un exportador
neto de commodities y entonces eso nos
está ayudando
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
este fenómeno de una proyección positiva
para la región vendría acompañado de una
fuerte presión inflacionaria el
encarecimiento de los precios sería del
11,2 por ciento en 2022 qué tan difícil
será manejarla
pues a ver una cosa es muy importante
que sepa la audiencia valentina y es que
latinoamérica comenzó su proceso de
ajuste monetario y mejor dicho de
incrementar las tasas de interés mucho
antes de lo que comenzó el resto del
mundo digamos en ese sentido fueron los
bancos centrales más responsables para
tratar de controlar la espiral
inflacionaria por ejemplo en brasil
brasil las tasas de interés del banco
central de brasil han incrementado las
tasas de interés en más de un 9%
entonces llegamos ha habido un
incremento fuerte y nosotros en el
mercado pensamos que eso va a ayudar a
evitar que se suba demasiado más de
inflación es más por ejemplo en el caso
nuestro en xp nosotros pensamos que la
inflación comienza a bajar en la mayoría
de los países de latinoamérica entre
abril y mayo es muy difícil dar
exactamente el momento pero entre abril
y mayo debería comenzar a bajar un poco
y eso y asumiendo obviamente que el
conflicto entre ucrania y rusia no se no
se deteriora mucho más que dios mediante
sea la realidad no entonces eso ayudaría
a que sean
las familias en latinoamérica tuvieran
que pagar un poco menos por su mercado
pero puntualmente tomando el ejemplo de
brasil hay perspectivas a la baja por el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
y la misma inflación ese caso se podría
repetir en economías vecinas es decir
cómo puede repercutir la situación de
brasil en la región al ser una de las
economías más grandes
pues paradójicamente brasil el fondo
monetario internacional incrementó la
expectativa de crecimiento en brasil
porque le había bajado bastante en enero
anterior y la economía se comportó un
poco mejor a lo que se esperaba ahora
aquí hay muchos riesgos valentina y el
mismo fondo monetario lo dice en sí no
estoy mal en la página 15 del documento
dice en estas situaciones tanto el nivel
de incertidumbre porque mira valentina
dios mediante este que está esta esta
cosa que esta tragedia tan horrible
entre ucrania y rusia se acaba en 15
días si se acaban 15 días yo creo que la
situación cambia radicalmente para bien
porque rusia y ucrania son unos grandes
productores de de commodities pues de
minerales de petróleo y de granos y eso
cambiaría mucho la dinámica si éstos se
empeoran que también dice el fondo
monetario internacional podría pasar
pues entramos en un escenario el familia
famosa estanflación porque europa que
tendría que comenzar a razonar a
racionalizar la energía por ejemplo
a alemania en una situación como la que
tuvo colombia se 20 para pagar los
teleoperadores los generadores no en
todos todas estas cosas dios mediante no
se ven pero en el escenario básicas y
que utiliza el fondo monetario
internacional
deberíamos estar con una caída de la
inflación de aquí a final de año